hey guys what's up I'm Alana and I am at
San Diego comic-con 2016 right now this
is my first ever San Diego comic-con and
oh my god is it insane being that it's a
convention that has toys sale I have
naturally spent far too much money maybe
one day I will go to a convention that
has a show floor it has stuff for sale
and not accidentally spend a [ __ ] ton of
money today it's not that day so I
thought that I would show you guys the
stuff that I picked up we have five
things here and I have two more that are
being shipped to me so yeah I [ __ ] up
ha so the first one we have here is none
other than the legendary Super Saiyan
really this one is an sdcc exclusive of
the pig watts SH Rolly and this is
basically a rerelease so they did
release this figure or a very similar
version of this figure quite a while ago
and it was still really hard to get so
they've rereleased it with kind of
changes to the call of the hair is a
little bit more green and he's also 7.5
inches tall which makes him taller than
the rest of the SH FiguArts line super
possible comes with two different heads
one of them is smoking and one of them
is yelling I imagine he's yelling
something along the lines of Kakarot
and it also comes with a bunch of
accessories but I don't think that I'm
going to open this one I really just
haven't decided yet I feel like because
it's an SEC C exclusive I might keep it
in the box
I don't know we'll see number two is the
lion cat from saga the comic book series
they did have two figures of two of the
characters available as well but the
biggest didn't look that good so I
passed on them went for the lion cat
statue instead this guy is 8 inches tall
let's open it up oh cool it comes
complete with its own choking has it so
here we have the lion cat a single tail
much better and it also comes with a
sweet face so apparently this one is a
limited edition of 3000 that's awesome
let's put him on his face ah it's
magnetic I love when they do that this
is what he looks like on his face I feel
like I should touch that necklace yeah
that's right don't know if I mentioned
Burling was around $70 this one was $75
so for the size of it
and the detail of it pretty happy with
that the next one is a pretty quick one
this is basically like a coffee table
book that I think is just incredibly
cool it features a whole bunch of
variant artwork of different artist
takes on 2d too
so basically a bunch of artists and fans
were given the 1/6 scale versions of
r2d2 and we're encouraged to customize
them for an art exhibition none of them
at the sale but these are all really
beautiful things that then they might
auction off sometime later this year
it's just like amazing different designs
and things that people have done with
base 2d - that's so cool
pirate one that's definitely one of my
favorites it was on sale at SDCC I think
for a discounted price I think it was
$20 when usually it's a little more
expensive but not exclusive just a
really really cool book with a whole
bunch of different people's creative
ideas okay next up is the NIC box so
this is a box full of 90 stuff also
obviously I realize that this is not the
ideal setup to do unboxings you are
sitting on top of a coffee machine in my
hotel room right now there's still a
bunch of like rubbish on the floor
behind me it's been a very busy show I
do the best with what I've got folks
okay we are opening it up most things
first we have a signal this is
Angelica's doll from the show Rugrats
that's cool I'm totally happy to have
that she's just as ugly as she looks in
the show a reptile
vinyl figure another Rugrats thing a
spunky plush this is the dog from
Rocko's Modern Life
his name is spunky I'm very concerned
about his legs that's not great some
glasses I think that these belong to
Chucky also from Rugrats we have a bunch
of Rugrats costa's that's little on the
front bed he's feel really cool they're
like a kind of vinyl a cat dog he
usb-drive
some iron on patches in the front that
we have
bankers Beavis what are the names I do
not remember the Beavers names they like
they they rhyme I totally don't remember
it's gonna come to me later
go on that's annoying some more angry
Beavis it's like Norbit is one of them
Norbit or something like that
seriously I hurt my mom I haven't seen
that show in so long but this is some
angry Beavis stationary then we have an
official Chucky shut I'm absolutely
going to wear this shut and a mysterious
white box
it's a sippy mug look as dumb knows the
Knik box I think is $50 I don't remember
exactly but it's currently a one-off box
but it's something that I thinking about
doing like a subscription service like a
loot crate or an ID block type of thing
you know I don't subscribe to any of
those kinds of things maybe that's one
that I actually would it's just like a
box full of nostalgia I'm down and last
but not least the most expensive thing
that I bought that's also not an
exclusive is this here
Bushido Batman featuring the reflection
of my lamp skull so play OPSEC I've been
making these variant Batman figures for
quite a while and they are freaking
awesome so I bought the prosciutto
Batman the spot in Batman and also the
steampunk Batman all at SDCC but this is
the only one that I actually physically
have right now the other ones will be
arriving sometime in the next month god
it looks good as the glare is ruining
everything but I swear he's beautiful
alright let's take him out alright he's
out of his box look how goddamn cool
that is cape there's like this beautiful
glossy red paint here it's even
different on the ends it's kind of a bra
see on the bottom like I just love that
it's like over-designed
I think but I'm so okay like that as is
with most play out sky pig as he also
comes with a whole bunch of different
weapons and interchangeable hands and
all this so much stuff so when I get
back home I will probably yeah give him
a cool weapon to hold but right now this
is what it looks like and I adore it but
yeah that's it for me today you guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this video
and I will see you all next time okay